[Music]
brothers and sisters let me introduce
you to Norway this is a European country
where the vast majority of people have
become irreligious there are 200,000
Muslims of a population of about 5
million and most of these 200,000
Muslims have no idea how to explain
Islam to their non-muslim friends and
neighbors but that needs to change Allah
sent his Messenger to call people to
Eternal success and that is why Muslims
in Norway are now establishing a Masid
and da Center to enhance the Norwegian
da but they cannot do this alone we need
to support them if you donate to this
cause you will inshallah reap the
rewards of thousands of Muslims coming
back to Islam and many of those will
become D and invite to Islam
you will share in the reward for all
those Shas and Good Deeds to come
inshallah so click the link and donate
now and share the video for extra reward
asalam alikum and Welcome to our Ramadan
series 2025 where we challenge some of
the allegations against Islam made by
islamophobes trying to undermine the
truthfulness of our faith we have
alhamdulillah Muhammad hijab with us who
will critically examine these
allegations expose the lies and clarify
the truth of Islam that such individuals
seek to distort the first allegation is
a statement by God sad during his
appearance on Tom Buu's podcast God sad
is a Canadian marketing professor of
libanese Jewish and Syrian Jewish
ancestry in this podcast he makes
several bold claims about Islam
including the assertation that it is not
a religion of Peace he argues that
Islam's core teachings and texts are
rooted in hatred for Jews let's look at
some of his claims and give our response
now Anis of Jew hatred in Islamic text
versus mind comp oops it doesn't look
too good so you don't need to believe
God sad but you have to do something
that most people to go back to our
earlier Point find very very difficult
to do it's called think it it's very
hard for me to go
and apply my cognition I'd rather just
hear Barack Obama tell me that Islam is
peace and it teaches peace it doesn't on
his deathbed Muhammad said promise me
that you will rid Arabia of the Jews
that doesn't sound very peaceful as long
as you are a good Demi and if I decide
that your daughter is really pretty and
I'd like to marry her you're going to
Fork her right Jew that's what it's
called to be a dii so let's summarize
his claims Islam is not a religion of
peace and subjugates Jews as a is what
is your response well well my response
to that is that the quotations that he's
bringing forward are not actually from
the primary sources of Islam that's why
it's very important when someone does
make a claim about Islam that they bring
forward the primary sources the the key
Point here is that if this were the case
if there were some kind of inherent um
bias or racism towards Jewish people
people of Jewish ancestry then why would
it be the case that the prophet Muhammad
wasam himself would marry
sopia who was of Jewish ancestry and
indeed her father was one of The
Chieftains of uh the Jewish tribes so
that's one thing and in fact you even
have a report which is authentically
narrated from the prophet Muhammad Sall
whereby um saf one of the wives of the
Prophet Muhammad wasallam came to him
and complained that some of the other
wives were speaking of her ancestry her
Jewish ancestry to which the prophet
Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam
replied that you you know say such and
such which is that ascribe your lineage
to harun which is a noble Prophet so in
other words he was in modern Parliament
giving her the tools to combat
anti-Semitism he was telling her exactly
how to uh do so and in fact he was
defending uh her so it doesn't seem to
me a plausible case that someone who has
a track record of not just marrying uh a
an ethnic Jew but actually arming uh
such ethnic Jew with the appropriate
intellectual arguments to um combat the
racism that such Jew was U facing would
in fact say the things that he has
ascribed or has eluded the prophet to
her so what would you say if someone
were to say that he only married her for
political reasons just to gain access to
control over the Jewish people well
that's not necessarily there was no
strategic uh political kind of result
from him marrying uh that particular Jew
like in other words it didn't didn't
have favor with the Jewish community no
one cared about that no one said oh he's
married safia from the three major
Jewish tribes
the the three there were three major
Jewish tribes at the time none of those
Jewish tribes in the Arabian Peninsula
thought oh just because he had married
such and such a person now we have a
more favorable view to him so it didn't
have that kind of thing where that would
be applicable is more with the Arab
tribes that did happen with the Arab
tribes so when he'd marri someone from
One Tribe another tribe yes there'd be
that aspect the tribes now the tribalism
would be reduced but it's not tribalism
between Jews and Arabs it was something
a little bit more um Sinister it's a
little bit more difficult to uh to
unpack uh and so it wasn't a matter of
he was doing it for strategic purpose uh
clearly there was interest on both sides
and he gave her choice saf by the way
which many people don't know this and
they haven't seen the reports of it but
he gave her a choice and he gave her a
time and he said to her if you want to
go go back to your family you can and
there's authentic narrations that said
that that if you want to you do not have
there's no compulsion in religion of
Islam so when you put all these facts
together uh alongside the fact that
Islam is the only religion and the Quran
is the only book which actually says
good things about the ethnic Jews
actually says good things about people
that are from B is such as for example
that Allah has um favored them of all
Humanity in Allah uh
that we
have we have chosen you and we and also
these words are used with people of
Jewish ancestry which is that we have
chose at one point in time that they
were the chosen people and the chosen
people is not because of their ethnicity
but it's because of how Allah has
favored them with prophets right Allah
has put prophets amongst their M midst
he has put Moses and he has put we would
say yes Jesus in fact as well which
ironically uh Jews of an theological
background would uh reject yes so I
think that these are flatly false claims
I think that's very clear to be honest
now I think the audience there's no
doubt about that but let's take one of
the other claims he made about the
treatment of them sure yeah so he
mentioned that Islam would encourage bad
treatment of the that's what his point
here so they will subjugate Jews you
want to have so if there is a Jew you
would make him a subordinate citizen in
the country what what would you say to
that well that's look the thing is thei
is as an individual there's three
categories of disbeliever According to
Islamic jurist Prudence okay one of the
categories is AI the other category is M
and the other category is Al yeah these
are three categories masallah you're
still here just make sure that you
donate by clicking the link below
because the rewards are
unimaginable
AI is an individual who's been granted
protection by the Islamic State okay uh
and who in turn pays taxes to the
Islamic State State some people say well
actually the taxes are discriminatory
taxes because alizia is a discriminatory
tax well in discriminatory in what sense
exactly they all say well maybe in their
minds they think it's a higher tax I've
looked at the books of I have not seen
that that is the case in fact there's
higher than what you didn't mention comp
so obviously the the the comparative
here would be zakat for the Muslims
right yes but there is no evidence to
show that a zi would have to pay more
more more taxes than a Muslim so in what
sense then is it discriminatory you
could say it's theological
discrimination because it has a
different name well it has a different
name because the word zakat itself in
the Arabic language comes from a roote
which indicates purification because
it's an act of worship okay so AI now
who's engaging paying jiz he's not
paying something which we consider to be
an act of worship he's paying taxes it's
an economic thing and that's something
we do in the West for example we Muslims
we pay taxes in the west so what really
is problematic about the fact that you
have non-muslims in a Muslim land that
have to pay some sort of taxes and in
fact in many cases if not I would argue
most cases that that would be less than
the zakat and all the that would be paid
by the Muslim maybe some of the points
that they could make is that zies have
lesser rights in what sense political
rights as an example yeah well there are
some things which zies will have lesser
rights in but they will also have lesser
responsibilities so for example I mean
think think of the following right
right are the obligated to do Jihad at
tal for example the proactive Jihad no
they're not obligated in fact they're
not even called to do it and some would
argue they shouldn't even do it so for
example the if there's I'm going to call
it conscription but if there's some kind
of a war that they have to do there are
some duties that they are alleviated
from doing rights and responsibilities
are two sides of the same coin if we
talk about people having lesser rights
um it's only unfair if it's commensurate
with them having less responsibilities
so yes they have less rights in the
cases where they have less
responsibilities and or in cases where
value is ascribed in a certain sense and
I will say this uh to a Muslim more so
than for example AI there there are some
cases like that as well however in in a
general sense the unfair charge that
there is discriminatory treatment or
that there is unfair or unequitable
treatment has not really been
substantiated with the evidence Y and so
I would say that in fact there's many
hadiths that Prophet or how to treat a
mu or somebody m in the Hadith by the
way includes thei for example the
Hadith that whoever kills a
non-combatant non-believer will not
smell the fragrance of Heaven this is a
Hadith and you know there are some other
hadiths which are whoever harms one than
me it's as if he has harmed me you know
these are serious Hadith of the Prophet
Muhammad sallu alaihi wasallam I I think
therefore with all of that evidence
uh for someone still to maintain this
unfair claim would be uh now being
really um I would say unfair to the text
and unacademic really because they're
not looking at both of these things
they're just um being a propagandist and
if it's all well and good if you want to
be a propagandist I mean he's a
marketing specialist I don't expect him
to be a theologian here or to come up
with a comparative study or any kind of
academic thing but what I do not forgive
are those people who host this Ultra
cidarian this person who is a flat face
liar yeah on their I do not forgive that
and they don't actually bring a
counterparty to challenge his ideas
that's actually unforgivable and it
shows that there's a greater agenda at
play maybe you should be that
counterpart I'm happy to be that
counterpart and of course uh I have been
in many uh situations and and debates
but there's a reason why they don't want
to face this is because they know that
every single point that can be made has
a counterargument they would rather
Their audience not hear those
counterarguments that's
true for your great answers to those
allegations I think they have been
refuted and to continue this kind of
work to to record these professional
videos as we are doing right now we need
your support this first episode of this
Ramadan series insh is inshah the
beginning of something great we will in
be recording multiple episodes like
these and multiple Series in the future
as well where will where we will be
challenging many of the allegations made
against Islam and if you guys take a
part of this a by donating to help us
produce this content and to combat these
islamophobes you will also be sharing in
that magnificent reward absolutely and I
just want to add to that actually is I
mean they are putting Millions into the
islamophobia industry the anti-muslim
industry the anti-islam industry they
are putting Millions into it they've got
massive platforms now alhamdulillah
we've got some big platforms as well but
let's be honest it doesn't compare to
their biggest platforms it doesn't
compare to Joe Rogan's platform it
doesn't compare to their media
mainstream media and stuff we uh are
trying our best to disseminate this
information but without the people we
can't do anything and that's why it's so
important that they realize that this is
that this is their best chance yeah of
having a voice without this they have no
voice there is no voice this is the best
chance donating to these there is no
better chance they can have having a
voice I think this Islam that and
Muhammad hijab platform yes come
together yes to challenge these
allegations I think this is the best
platform and in if we the Muslims can
come together to build this platform to
the biggest one representing the values
of Islam in society in millions of
people will benefit from these these
videos that we produce so I think all of
you guys it's the month of Ramadan
should take part in this great cause and
click the link now and give something
for the sake of Allah subhana tala and
wait that this will be heavy on your
scale of Good
Deeds see you in the next episode
[Music]